Let's add a new style sheet and
a media query that applies only when
the view port is wider than 500 pixels.
I'll add a new linked CSS file with a
media attribute, and I'll set the value
to screen and min-width 500 pixels so
that it's only applied when
the screen is over 500 pixels.
You may see references to other
media types, but ignore them.
Media types like handheld, projected, or
embossed never really gained any
traction and don't do anything.
Just stick with screen and
print if you think your users
are going to want to print your page.
I'll take a look at the style
sheet that gets applied and
see that it changes
the background color to blue.
All right.
I'll reload the page in the browser.
Notice that the background remains
white, but as I start to resize it,
once it hits that 500 pixel break point,
the screen turns blue because
the media query's been matched.